pourquoi bonjour je libre que se
passe-t-il due à des ennuis tu pas moi
mais c'est casimir qui m'inquiète que
lui arrive-t-il encore je ne sais pas on
regarde je ne vois rien d'extraordinaire
il doit réparer quelque chose à sa malle
magique tu as déjà vu réparé le
carburateur d'une malle toi parce qu'il
a parlé d'un carburateur
oui tu commences à comprendre mais oui
évidemment c'est plutôt bizarre étant
donné qu un carburateur est une caisse
de moteur et que je n'ai jamais vu de
malle magique avec un carburateur je te
garantis qui le traitent de tous les
noms de son carburateur julie pourquoi
ne pas lui avoir demandé de jeter fois
mais il m'a envoyé propres qui lui
disait des tas de choses que je
comprenais pas le bon ben je vais y
aller il faut tirer ça au clair qu'ils
m'écoutent je sais très bien que casimir
n'a jamais été ni dangereux ni méchant
oui mais comment bizarre julie reste
dans son kiosque ému et je vais y aller
il ne t'en fais pas casimir qu'est-ce
que ça hein c'est moi françois ne
dérangez pas le plus grand savant de la
terre bientôt je ne saurais plus de ce
siècle
si cette cochonnerie carburateur veut
bien marché c'est peut-être un gicleur
qui est bouché qu'est-ce que ça ait un
gicleur et bien c'est une des pièces du
carburateur par lesquelles passent les
sens des voix s'est hissée évidemment
casimir il est complètement bouché que
les chiffes ou un week-end merci là et
voilà il est débouchée arbon tu croire
mais les états unis remédie dont casimir
en échange du var était de jouer les
grands savants et tu va m'expliquer
pourquoi deux amis un moteur dont un
mâle magique
bon puisque tu m'as aidé je serai tout à
raconter là j'ai retrouvé dans mon
grenier les plans d'une machine à
explorer le temps
oui cette machine avec inventé par mon
arrière-grand-père tu veux dire une
machine à voyager dans le passé
exactement mais enfin casimir c'est
impossible
les machines à voyager dans le passé ou
ou dans le futur sont des inventions
d'écrivains ça ne peut pas exister hors
jeu j'aurais rien dû te dire tu as
sultan la mémoire de mon
arrière-grand-père menon que du mur ce
je suis certain que ton grand père était
quelqu'un de formidable mais il est sûr
qu'on ne peut pas revenir dans le passé
tu crois eh bien tu vas voir regarde je
vais que commencer viens avec moi si tu
veux il faut manger sur la plateforme
non merci casimir je n'y tiens pas non
non mais nous allons tous assisté avec
joie à ton départ comme tu veux il a à
peine les enfants et julie je voudrais
leur faire mais au revoir julie vient
voir les enfants venez venez venez avec
moi vous asseoir sur le banc
nous allons assister au départ de
casimir dans le passé si si c'est ce
qu'il projette tout cela mes amis
j'espère vous dire au revoir et non
point à dieu je vais partir faire un
voyage dans le temps
oui je compte retrouver mon ancêtre
casimir us premier qui vivait il ya 7
millions d'années si par hasard je ne
reviens pas j'espère que vous ne m'aurez
pas oublié j'ai tout soit toi casimir
couvre toi bien mais n'est pas par julie
ma malle magique me fournira des
vêtements pour chaque époque
attention je mets le contact
mais vous êtes encore là je suis bien
content parce que je ne sais pas à
quelle époque appartient ce chapeau où
suis-je
ah bon la plaie au premier moment merci
mes amis je repars dans une autre époque
attention je mets le contact
encore vous et est maintenant où suis-je
isabelle à la révolution et casimir et
déguisés en personnages révolutionner
paris la résolution seulement la tête
bon j'ai pas fait un très grand voyage
bonjour je repars un peu plus loin
c'était une attention jamais le contact
à mes amis cette fois j'ai un très beau
costume
vous pouvez vous me dire à quelle époque
je suis là les enfants isabelle louis
xiii et casimir et en mousquetaire du
roi formidable bon écoutez je vous je
tiens à aller encore plus loin dans le
temps je repars attention contact puis
je savoir à quelle époque j'étais
transporter les enfants allant casimir
vient de la rome antique
ce costume s'appelle une toge et sur la
tête il a une couronne de lauriers
c'était césar qui portait la couronne de
lauriers bien je vais remonter encore
plus loin avait françois avec emi russe
tiens me suis-je maintenant xavier moi
je suis un gaulois
ah bon alors cette fois j'ai changé
depuis mais pas d'époque
j'ai dû me tromper mais ça fait rien je
repars contact tient à quelle époque
suis-je maintenant l'histoire la
préhistoire mais c'est formidable alors
je vais revoir mon ancêtre à casimir
casimiri il ya quelque chose qui ne va
pas quoi tu n'as pas pu voyager dans le
passé puisque du toujours parmi nous il
y a que tes vêtements qu'ils aient
changé
salah la malle magique a tenu ses
promesses mais toi tu n'as pas pu
voyager dans le passé mais convaincu
maintenant oui tout à fait je suis
convaincu d'une chose je n'aurais jamais
dû le laisser toucher mon moteur tu as
tout de craquer
[Rires]